[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
على وقعه معارك متجدده في محيط القصر
الجمهوري بالعاصمه السودانيه الجيش يؤكد
صدام محاولات لاستهداف مقري القياده
العسكريه لمنطقتي الخرطوم وبحري والدعم
السريع يقول انه تصدى لسلسله هجمات على
مواقعه بينما تتوسع رقعه الاشتباكات في
مدينه الاوبيض غربيه البلاد تحذيرات من
نفاد المستلزمات الطبيه مع توقف مزيد من
المستشفيات عن العمل بسبب تدهور الاوضاع
الامنيه جراء الاشتباكات في السودان
ومفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين تحذر في حديث
للجزيره من ان عدد الفارين الى دول الجوار
قد يتجاوز 800 الف شخص
بعد هجوم رئيس مجموعه باجنر على وزير
الدفاع الروسي وتهديده بسحب قواته من
بخموت في غضون خمسه ايام وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تعلن بدء هجوم جديد للسيطره على
المدينه بدعم من القوات المحموله جوا
والقوات الاوكرانيه تؤكد صد عشرات الهجمات
على محور ضخمه مجله الايكونوميست
البريطانيه تثير عاصفه من الجدل في تركيا
قبل ايام من الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد
نشرها مقالا يدعي تفوق المعارضه على
اردوغان في نتائج الانتخابات مرفقه ذلك
بعبارات انقذوا الديمقراطيه وعلى اردوغان
الرحيل ووزراء اتراك وسياسيون وصحفيون
ورؤساء بلديات يعبرون عن استيائهم من نشر
مثل هذه العبارات ويعتبرونه تدخلا في شؤون
بلادهم
الى اللقاء